It never fails.
You’re watching television and someone is
circling the drain, in the toilet that is
their life.
The noise from the heart monitor affirms they’re
still alive, with its consistent, rhythmic
beeps.
All of the sudden, alarms start going off.
On the monitor- the dreaded “flat-line”.
Doctors begin rushing in.
One of them always seems to yell, “Hand
me the paddles; we’re losing him!”
The machine is charged, and miraculously the
heart is shocked back to life, saving the
day!
(But only after a suitably dramatic number
of zaps and someone inevitably shouting “LIVE
DAMN YOU!”)
The problem is that, in real life, you’ll
be accomplishing nothing by shocking a “flat-line”.
Unless you like your meat well done that is.
Medically, a “flat-line” is known as asystole,
meaning no (heart) contraction.
It might seem common sense that if there is
no contraction you might want to contract
it with a shock.
The truth about why this will never “restart”
the heart lies in how the heart creates its
life giving beat.
In the end, it all comes down to electrolytes.
The heart typically receives approximately
60-100 “shocks” per minute, usually from
specialized pacemaker cells in the right upper
portion of the heart, known as the Sinoartrial
node (SA node).
These specialized cells will naturally create
an electrical differential between the inside
of the cell and the outside.
Once that differential is at just the right
amount, it will send a “shock” down, and
throughout, the heart muscle causing it to
contract.
Once this electrical signal is produced, it
will generally go completely throughout the
heart through the cardiac conduction system.
You might be thinking right now, if the heart
creates a shock to get a contraction, why
won’t shocking it externally get the job
done?
Well, the devil is in the details.
The SA node creates an electrical differential
using electrolytes like potassium, sodium
and calcium.
I won’t be going into a college level physiology
lecture, as this article would be way too
long and I imagine most of you aren’t interested
in reading such an essay.
However, for the purposes of understanding
why shocking asystole doesn’t work, I will
very briefly summarize what’s going on “under
the hood” here.
These electrolytes all have specific electrical
charges that pass through your cell walls
using channels named after the electrolyte-
sodium channels, calcium channels etc.
Potassium generally lies inside of your cell
before it contracts; sodium and calcium generally
reside outside the cell.
When you have a blood pressure (if you didn’t
you would quickly be dead), sodium is naturally
forced inside your cell.
This also causes potassium to be forced out
of your cell creating an electrical potential.
Once that potential gets high enough, it opens
up calcium channels which are voltage regulated.
When the calcium channels are opened up, sodium
and calcium rush inside the cell creating
just the right amount of charge.
Once that charge is reached, the heart sends
out its shock, known as depolarization.
So where does that impulse go once the SA
node creates it?
When the SA node sends out its life sustaining
impulse, it immediately shocks the atria.
The pulse then gets “held up” in another
set of cells called the Atrioventricular node,
or AV node for short.
This allows for the bottom part of the heart
to receive the blood from the top part.
The AV node then transmits the impulse down
to the bundle of His (no, not the bundle of
hers, sorry ladies) and then to two pathways
called the right and left bundle branches.
It then gets transmitted to the rest of the
Ventricles through what are called Purkinje
fibers.
All together this “shock” causes the atria
to contract, then the ventricles.
The wonder of a pulse!!
This electrical conduction is what doctors
are looking at when they are staring at the
heart monitor.
Generally speaking, this impulse creates a
squeeze that actually creates your pulse.
There are times however, that this isn’t
the case.
A person could have a normal looking electrical
conduction on the monitor and still have no
pulse.
The phenomenon is known as Pulse-less Electrical
Activity (PEA).
This is one of the reasons why doctors still
need to check pulses, and blood pressures,
even if the person is hooked up to a heart
monitor.
When someone is in cardiac arrest and has
no pulse, depending on how the electrical
conduction system is working, they might need
to be shocked.
There are numerous electrical rhythms that
can present themselves in cardiac arrest.
I will touch on the most common, and why shocking
works.
The most common heart rhythm just after someone
goes into cardiac arrest is known as Ventricular
fibrillation.
When the SA node fails to create a beat, countless
other cells within the heart attempt to create
the beat instead.
The result is numerous areas of the heart
that “shock” it all at the same time,
from different directions.
Instead of a steady contracting beat, what
you get is a heart that looks like it’s
having a seizure.
The effect is a heart that doesn’t pump
blood through it.
The only way to get all of these different
areas of the heart (foci) to work in unison
again is to shock it with more electricity
than the cells themselves are creating.
When you shock these cells with this large
amount of electricity, it forces all of the
electrolytes out of the cells at the same
time.
The hope, and it’s really just a hope, is
that the heart’s normal operation of electrolytes
passing across the cell membranes in an organized
fashion will take over again.
Here is the devil in the shocking details.
When someone is in asystole (flat-lined),
there is no electrical differential that the
monitor can pick up.
Essentially, there are no specific electrolytes
inside the cell, compared to outside the cell,
with different electrical potentials to create
an impulse.
If you attempted to shock this, you wouldn’t
be doing anything.
There are no electrolytes to force out of
the cells that are any different than the
ones that are already outside the cells.
All you would get is more flat-line.
In fact, after every shock ever given to someone
in cardiac arrest, the rhythm created for
a few seconds is asystole, with the heart
rhythm temporarily stopped.
It takes a few seconds for the normal pathways
to get going again.
If you had asystole before you shocked it,
all you would do is burn the heart with the
heat created from the shock.
As every steak lover knows, don’t burn the
meat!
Medium-well please… unless you’re in Texas,
then from my experience it’s “rare”
only and ordering anything different will
see the chef come out from the kitchen and
slap you in the face.
(Note: The red juice in such rare red meat
is not actually blood)
In the end, it’s a Hollywood myth that you
would treat asystole (flat-line) with a shock.
You must first have some sort of electrical
impulse to work with.
Science 1, Hollywood 0.